good evening everybody
welcome to another night of Santa Fe Institute
lecture public lecture marvelous to see
such a good crowd especially with a storm
blowing in the middle of winter and so on
um so um first I want to give some acknowledgments
the lecture is supported by very generously by the
McKinnon Family Foundation with added support
of course from the lensig and from the Santa
Fe reporter and we're very very grateful
to all of those for giving the kind of
support that we need in order to bring these
kinds of lectures to the Santa Fe Community
uh my name is Jeffrey West yes please please
uh my name is Jeffrey West and I'm on the faculty
at the Santa Fe Institute and I'm really delighted
and have the honor to introduce tonight's speaker
Sean Carroll Sean is on our external faculty
um and uh is also a what's called a frat part
of that fractal faculty which is a part of the
these are people that are invited to become part
of the center for institute who are particularly
distinguished so we have many very distinguished
people one of which you will hear tonight Sean
so um Sean is a physicist his pedigree is through
Villanova University as an undergraduate and then
Harvard as a graduate student in astronomy
where he did his thesis on cosmology gravity
astrophysics and so on and that is sort of
permeated his career he's at a very distinguished
career in areas associated with that but dealing
more and more with fundamental questions and that
of course is going to be the main theme of the
topic tonight as he discusses quantum mechanics
um after his PhD at Harvard he had various
postdocs he was on the faculty for a while at the
University of Chicago but for the past many years
he's been on the research faculty at Caltech and
has just left there to take a very distinguished
chair at Johns Hopkins University I don't know if
it was it was on the yes there we go Johns Hopkins
as a chair of natural philosophy with appointments
in both physics and philosophy just to give you
a sense of the breadth and depth of thinking
that the charm brings um he's maybe well known to
many of you because um he's a prolific writer he's
written four books and I'm going to read the names
to you because they sort of summarize some of the
main interests and contributions that Sean has
made and their cute titles I must say one is from
eternity to here which is about the arrow of time
second book he wrote was the particle at the end
of the universe about the infamous Higgs boson and
we just celebrated 10 years since the discovery
of the Higgs boson third is the big picture on
the origins of life meaning and the universe
itself but ontology and the last something deeply
hidden about the foundations of quantum mechanics
which we'll hear about tonight and of course
you presumably wouldn't be here if you didn't
know what quantum mechanics sort of is that it's
foundational in terms of physics it's been almost
100 years since it was developed in the 1926-27
and it's been incredibly successful enormously
successful it underlies many of the things that
you're familiar with like lasers and materials
and superconductivity and so forth enormously
successful but but also it's brought a bunch of
paradoxes and maybe the biggest Paradox is that we
still don't really understand at the deepest level
what it means or what it's actually what some of
those symbols that we use actually are manifesting
and I thought what I would do is uh just before we
let Sean take the stage is read you a few quotes
because of people famous people that you have
heard of make their statements about quantum
mechanics I mean because the two major things that
quantum mechanics brought that shook the world at
least the world of physics were one and introduced
the fact that things seem to be probabilistic that
there was a probabilistic stochastic element to a
fundamental questions of physics and secondly the
role of the Observer somehow we had to be involved
in the measurements uh to to make sense of what
was what quantum mechanics was about that is it
brought a certain degree of subjectivity to it
so in terms of probability Einstein made the
famous comment God does not play dice with the
universe and uh often in terms of this idea that
it was this kind of weird subjective the the idea
that there had to be an observer came an extreme
statement for example I got one here from Martin
Reese who was the astronomer Royal of the United
Kingdom the universe exists because we are aware
of it so all of this is somehow a construction
of the mind and Einstein had already made a
statement in refuting that by saying do you really
believe the Moon is only there when you look at it
um and finally two things one is from
Richard Feynman who said if you think
you understand quantum mechanics you
don't understand quantum mechanics
and Schrodinger who was one of the great founders
of quantum mechanics who said I don't like it and
I'm sorry I have anything had anything to do
with it so with that let's hear from Sean and
we may have an historic moment when indeed
all these questions will be resolved sure
thank you Jeffrey thank you to are you hearing me
is that true you're not hearing me you are hearing
me now very good thank you Jeffrey thank you
everyone at the Santa Fe Institute for inviting
me and everyone in Santa Fe for coming out it
occurs to me this is a picture of one of my cats
her name is Ariel I hope you get the joke the your
quantum mechanics uh aficionados will get the joke
of the picture here Ariel's Ariel's brother's
name is caliban which I only bring up because
they're named after characters from Shakespeare's
The Tempest which reminds me of the weather that
is going on in Santa Fe here right now which is
doing its best to be tempestuous so I'm especially
thankful to all of you to coming through uh the
downpour to get here and I've given a talk about
this subject many times before but I did try to
make this one different I'm going to try out some
new material on you folks so I hope that you get
some feedback on whether it works and I thought I
would start just by giving it away I'm telling you
the punch line okay because it's not like a magic
show where I tell you a bunch of things and then
at the end it's a surprise I want you to really
understand quantum mechanics and I have to say
is lovely uh and as appreciative as I am about
Jeffrey's introduction the Feynman quote is fake
news he never said that he did say uh I think that
nobody understands quantum mechanics that's what
he said he didn't say If you think you understand
it you don't he said no one understands it whether
you think you do or not but what is important is
that it is understandable and you know some
of us think we do understand it we may or may
not be right but even if we're wrong it is not
magic it is physics it is science and it can be
understood so just to rub in what a large ask I'm
making of you here tonight I have a picture here
of the universe it's zoomed in to a little tiny
part of the universe and it's supposed to remind
you of how we often think about reality about the
world namely it's made of stuff there's a chair
there's a book there's a floor here's a podium
in front of me and it's arranged in space right
the podium is to my front I'm behind it and so on
and so forth and that's the world that's the world
we live in and the job of physics is to explain
it quantum mechanics I'm going to claim says no
that is not what the world is when we look at
the world we don't see the entirety of reality
reality is much richer than that and in fact what
reality is I'm not going to keep it a secret is a
superposition of many different ways that stuff
can be arranged in space and don't worry I will
tell you exactly what it's meant by all of those
words but the great thing is that reality can
be divided up into subsections each of which acts
like a world comprised of stuff arranged in space
so the crucial thing here is that you're not
saying that reality is a bunch of things in
space space is one of the things in reality and
there's many many other copies of space in reality
now that's a big ask that is a lot to swallow
you should not just take my word for it so what
I want to start to do is I'm going to sneak up on
you I'm going to say a bunch of things based on
you know historical real experiments and thoughts
and so forth and you're gonna be going uh-huh and
then at the end I'm going to realize what it
all means and you're going oh no I don't like
that anymore so that's where we're going to go so
it starts over 100 years ago and you know we've
seen this picture right on the right here of the
atom classic picture physics departments use it
as their logo and so forth the Rutherford atoms
put together around 1909 it looks like a little
solar system you have a nucleus in the middle
electrons spiraling around it even though this
is an iconic picture that is still thought of as
the symbol of physics or atomic energy or whatever
it was instantly known to be false as soon as
people suggested it it can't possibly be right
and the reason why is it you know it looks like
a familiar thing the solar system but those
electrons are moving very fast if you plug in the
numbers and when you take an electrically charged
particle like an electron and you move it like
in a circle it gives off radiation it gives off
electromagnetic waves the electromagnetically
charged particle has an electric field that is
trying to point to it and if you move it the field
has to shift and those shifts Ripple out at the
speed of light and we call them light that's what
they are electromagnetic radiation so if this were
what the atom was like it should be giving off
radiation very very quickly and you can even do
the math you can ask how long would it take for
those electrons to lose energy and to spiral in
and just settle down there where the nucleus
is the answer is 10 to the minus 11 seconds
okay 1 100 of a billionth of a second so we
can do the experiment there we did it this is
not what happens this prediction is that all of
ordinary matters wildly unstable and Adam should
collapse if this were the real atom that the
real Universe was based on so something is wrong
about it and they knew that right away they knew
electromagnetism and so forth now it took a while
I'm skipping some steps here it took a while to
figure out what was going on uh separately people
like Max Planck and Albert Einstein had suggested
that light which is a wave had particle-like
properties so to solve this problem people like
Louis de broy suggested that maybe particles
like electrons have wave-like properties that they
really are more like waves than like particles and
what happens then is that you rather than having
an orbit around the nucleus the wave that is the
electron has a shape I say wave but it's really a
field of some sort that can take various different
shapes if you were in a chemistry class in high
school or college or are a chemist for that matter
you know about the orbital that electrons can
have in atoms those orbitals are just ways that
the electron wave can settle down and none of them
are all concentrated right there in the nucleus
because that would actually take a lot of energy
there's a minimum energy state that it wants to go
in but if you have a lot of electrons they start
filling up the other levels as well and therefore
you have chemistry in the periodic table and all
these wonderful things okay notice that nowhere in
here this is the beginning of quantum mechanics
but nowhere in here that I say the universe
is made of little discrete bits that is not what
quantum mechanics says if anything is the opposite
the universe is made of waves but when you solve
the equation for the waves you find that the waves
take certain discrete shapes and that's where the
word Quantum comes from and very quickly after
this idea came along people did the obvious thing
which is they found an equation for the waves and
this is known as the Schrodinger equation there
will not be a quiz don't worry the point is that
you do need to understand that big Greek letter
PSI that where it says for wave function Psi Psi
is the wave function a really Dopey name for a
very profound idea but we'll be talking about it
a lot Schrodinger came up with this equation that
says how the wave function of the electron or of
anything else changes over time and it basically
says the amount of energy in the wave tells you
how fast it's changing with time so physicists
love this this is this is looking really good okay
physicists already in the 1920s they loved waves
because they knew about electromagnetism which
are electromagnetic waves that was very familiar
and they certainly love equations because then
you can assign problem sets to your students
and that's what physics is being all about
so it was all good in 1926 but then someone
pointed out the obvious lurking problem with this
which is that physics is based on observations
and measurements data that you collect and when
you look at electrons you don't see waves you see
particles here's a real image a real little movie
this is a radioactive Source in a cloud chamber
giving off particles it's radioactive so it
decays it can emit particles and you can use the
schrodiger equation to predict what the particle
wave function should look like and the answer is
they come out as a big spherical Cloud moving in
every direction that is not what you see in the
picture all of these little lines are individual
particles being emitted by the radioactive source
and they leave a straight line trajectory like
they're a particle with a location moving away
from the source so this is very strange we're
saying that to explain the structure of atoms
and matter we need to imagine that electrons
are really waves but we never see the waves when
we look at them this is the beginning as Jeffrey
mentioned in his introduction of the quantum
weirdness that we need to talk about what we see
no other Theory of physics ever needed to do that
this is why quantum mechanics is hard maybe it's
difficult to measure things in classical mechanics
but you can always do it in principle to whatever
accuracy you want but in quantum mechanics as soon
as you start trying to make sense of things it's
almost as if what you're saying is that electrons
behave like waves when you're not looking at them
but when you look at them they start behaving
like particles now this should drive you crazy
you should be getting itchy you should be like
that doesn't sound like it makes sense to me
what is the electron care whether I am looking
at it or not it's an electron it just does its
electron things so this is very upsetting it
I mean it seems sort of in a clutchy way if
the data but it can't be right so what do you
do what do you do about this sort of crisis in
understanding what's going on so what we did uh
almost 100 years ago is we assembled the world's
greatest Minds the smartest physicist that we knew
assembled in Brussels in Belgium for this Solvay
conference in 1927 the fifth Solvay conference uh
this is one of the best and brightest collections
of people ever assembled in one small room half
the people in this picture won the Nobel Prize
or would win the Nobel Prize soon Marie Curie who
you can recognize there she won two Nobel prizes
you have to be twice as good as many of you will
know but you have Einstein you have boar you have
Dirac you have Schrodinger you have Heisenberg
all the big names in quantum physics got him into
a room they talked they had a few Belgian ales
they thought about this problem of it seems like
our best theory of the world says that electrons
behave like waves when you're not looking at them
and then like particles when you are what can
possibly be the Deep hidden truth behind this
and at the end of the week they came out and they
announced okay we've got it figured out here it is
electrons behave like waves
when you're not looking at them
and they behave like particles when you are
that was the resolution they bit the bullet
they said that's it moving on all of our deep
questions have been answered and that became
the consensus View and I say consensus there
were some objectors Einstein and Schrodinger
also they both they never believed this they
both objected to this point of view I actually
want to say something about Einstein because I'll
say two things number one he was a smart cookie
maybe you've heard that before it's true but
number two if anything Einstein is underrated
there's this myth that goes around that you
know in later years Einstein became kind of
a conservative old fuddy-duddy he couldn't keep up
with the new Quantum hotness and so he sort of was
uh relegated to the sidelines that is entirely
wrong historically for one thing Einstein when
this picture was taken was younger than I am now
so I refuse to describe him as an old fuddy-duddy
but also Einstein number one did as much as anyone
literally to help invent quantum mechanics in the
first place that's what he won the Nobel Prize
for and number two even later years he understood
quantum mechanics at least as well as anybody
else what he didn't do was accept the hectoring
that he got from the rest of the participants
saying all the questions have been answered
to Einstein quantum mechanics was a step in the
right direction but it wasn't finished yet and
the thing is he was right he was completely right
about everything he said in these arguments but he
lost the public relations battle okay so you
know that when you're Einstein and you can't
convince your fellow physicists it's an uphill
battle the story that was promulgated after the
conference was this kind of recipe for dealing
with wave functions in quantum mechanics you
have a wave function Capital PSI over here some
spread over X and Y positions in space and then
there's a black box that you plug it into you
say what happens if I observe if I measure the
position of the electron and the answer is
you can't predict exactly what you will see
but you can predict the probability that you
will see the electron in a certain place you
always see it in a certain place you don't see
the wave you will see a particle the probability
of seeing the particle at any one location is
given by the pre-existing wave function at that
location squared okay so where there's more wave
there's more probability for seeing the particle
so again uniquely in the history of physics we
have two rules two sets of rules sorry to describe
quantum mechanics one set of rules for when you're
not looking at it systems are described by wave
functions the wave functions perfectly obey
Schrodinger's equation then when you measure
them a completely new set of rules takes force
and again that never happened before in physics
the wave function will collapse to a particular
value it will look particle like and there's a
probability that you get different measurement
outcomes so this is known as the Copenhagen
interpretation but people disagree about what the
Copenhagen interpretation actually says so I just
call it the textbook version of quantum mechanics
I'm not fooling you for those of you who are not
physicists this is what we teach our students
at Johns Hopkins or Caltech or anywhere this
is what we tell them about quantum mechanics
if we start asking questions we kick them out
no you laugh nervous laughter
the reason why you should be a little bit upset
about this is because the textbook picture of
quantum mechanics is clearly unacceptable as
a fundamental theory of nature we'd like to
think that quantum mechanics is the best most
fundamental most basic idea we have about how
nature works and yet we tell this crazy story
about what's going on so let me highlight two
ways in which this is uh unacceptable and again
by unacceptable I don't mean false I just mean
clearly not the final answer clearly there are
some questions being left open here so the famous
one is the measurement problem so in those rules
for quantum mechanics we have When You observe the
system you get certain things happening what
does that mean what counts as a measurement
can a video camera measure something can a mouse
measure something what about a person who needs
glasses and they're not they don't have their
glasses on what if I just squint at the system
how quickly does it happen when does it happen
why does it involve you know a conscious kind
of Observer and you can see how a whole book
industry about Quantum healing and Quantum
yoga and Quantum leadership is going to spring
up in the aftermath of this because this way of
talking seems to put human agency at the center
of the universe in a very non-copernican way
though whatever the answers are the point is the
Copenhagen interpretation doesn't tell us what the
answers are and that is too vague to be the final
answer to a theory of fundamental physics then
there is the reality problem which different
people also have different angles on so we
talk about the wave the electron wave or the wave
function as we call it in the post Schrodinger era
what is that is it a real thing like an
electromagnetic wave it's a real thing you can
measure it you can put a little magnetometer or
a charge and you could measure where the electric
field magnetic field are pointing but we said you
can't measure you can't observe the wave function
it's never what you see is it real or is it just
a way of making predictions about reality and you
can see how it's going even further in the spooky
woo-woo directions it's almost like we're bringing
reality into existence by thinking about it or
looking at it or other bad things that lead to
bad movies and and bad TV shows okay but it should
be science so we should think about this and we
should be able to answer these questions let's
think about the reality but let me admit that for
all these questions not everyone agrees so I wrote
a op-ed piece for the New York Times where I say
nobody understands quantum mechanics and that's
a problem and I expected at least a few of my
colleagues to email me saying what do you mean I
understand quantum mechanics and I was pleasantly
surprised it was only one colleague who did email
me about that but the point is that people don't
agree within the field so even if one of us is
right there is no consensus among physicists
about the answers to these questions so from now
from to this point to this in the talk I've been
saying things that are true I hope I'll be saying
things true in the future but I'm going to be more
opinionated I'm going to give you my angle on
it uh it needs to be a six lecture series for
me to give you everybody else's angle on it so
you can invite them to give you their pictures
I want to talk about the reality problem
what is the wave function is it something
real is that what the real world is it's like
a wave function or is it just a tool for making
predictions the answer is it's real in my view
again not everyone agrees here's the evidence
the famous double slit experiment there's other
pieces of evidence but this is a good famous One
let's say you have a wave and this was actually
an experiment that was done in the 1800s for
light to show that light was a wave before we
knew because Isaac Newton thought that light was
a bunch of particles Maxwell said it was a wave
the wave theory run out one out Thomas Young took
a light and he pointed it from a source at two
at a barrier with two slits in it two openings
and then if it is a wave that wave should
appear on the other side of the two openings
in a spherical pattern so it's almost like
two different waves are coming out from the
two different openings and then what you get is
interference so because there's two different
sources of the Waves some places the waves will
combine and reinforce other places they'll have
opposite signs and they will cancel each other
out so what you see in the middle there is an
interference pattern bands of light and dark
if a wave passes through those two openings
in quantum mechanics what you predict if you
pass a single electron through those two slits
is that the electron you're not observing it
you're not measuring you're just letting it
go through the two slits it acts like a wave and
therefore you should see an interference pattern
the thing is when you detect it on the screen
you're detecting it there you are measuring it
so you just see a DOT and a DOT is not going
to show you an interference pattern but what
you can do is just send one electron through and
then another one and then another one and then
another one and what happens is what you see on
the right that's real data you see interference
patterns emerge so even though you're sending in
the electrons one by one and they they kind of
behave like particles When You observe them along
the way they behave like waves they interfere
it's hard for a representation of our ability
to predict future experiments to interfere with
itself real waves interfere with themselves real
waves go up and down and can cancel each other out
this is exactly the behavior you would expect if
the wave function were something real so you know
you can wriggle out of this physicists are very
clever they can read a lot of anything but let's
not work too hard yet let's just go with what
seems to be being suggested by the data the wave
function is a real thing you're willing to go with
me on that sure the electron wave function's real
thing I mean it holds up the podium right because
of the atoms have shapes because the electron wave
function well there's a complication that was
invented by Guess Who Albert Einstein and his
collaborators still thinking very profoundly about
quantum mechanics they invented or popularized
this idea called entanglement Einstein podolsky
and Rosen 1935. so consider a particle and let's
just think of it as a particle right now we know
it's really a wave function but that's okay if
it's a very heavy particle it will just sit there
but it's an unstable particle like an unstable
nucleus or a Higgs boson or something okay imagine
this particle can Decay into two other particles
and you can predict exactly what's going to
happen you can use the Schrodinger equation
quantum mechanics despite its conceptual murkiness
as far as making predictions is concerned it's
incredibly precisely quantitative and successful
so you predict that the unstable particle decays
into two particles but you also predict that those
two particles have wave functions so they don't
move off on an individual track they move off in
these spherical clouds that's the prediction that
the Schrodinger equation makes and that's fine
that's good but then you're going to measure
you're going to observe you're going to ask well
what direction do I see the particle coming out
of right and this is what we actually do with
the Large Hadron Collider or Geneva and so forth
we measure particles coming out of collisions
and decays all the time so what you will see
if you look for particle number one let's say
you'll see that it's moving in a certain direction
you don't see the wave you see it looking like a
particle but now notice that the original particle
the blue one the unstable one wasn't moving by
by Construction so it had zero momentum it had
no motion and momentum is conserved therefore
you know if you see one particle moving in One
Direction the other particle has to be seen moving
in the other direction because the two final Decay
products must also have zero total momentum if
you're moving in opposite directions to cancel
each other out and what that means is that even
if you had just observed particle number one
you would instantly know what direction you were
going to measure particle number two moving in
even if it was really far away if you waited a
really long time this bugged Einstein but who
cares who cares about what bugged Einstein
you just want to think about what it means
for us we accept this as real somehow and this
is true if you you can do this again and again
you measure it again measure particle one in a
different direction particle two will always be
moving the opposite direction you can do this
over and over again however many times you want
what is going on it can't be the case that
particle 1 has a wave function where you can
predict only what direction it's going to come
in with a certain probability and particle 2 has
a wave function you can only predict its thing
somehow there's a connection between them that's
what entanglement is and the answer at the level
of the symbols and equations is perfectly clear
entanglement implies there is only one wave
function even when you have two particles it's
not that you have a wave function for particle 1
and a wave function for particle two you have a
single wave function that depends on both where
you will observe particle 1 and particle two or
what their momentum is or whatever you want to
observe about them so if you think here it's
not a great plot because I just plotted a similar
thing meaning something different but here's the
positions that you could measure particle 1 and
particle 2 in there's a possible wave function of
it so what the wave function is doing is assigning
a number to every possible location that every
particle could be in and this is not just for two
particles if you have the whole universe you would
have a wave function of the universe and what
is the wave function of the universe it assigns
a number to every possible configuration that
everything in the universe could be in and you
square that number and you get the probability of
actually seeing the universe in that configuration
so the point of this discussion is there's only
one wave function and therefore the wave function
is a little bit different than the waves that
you're used to like the electromagnetic wave and
things like that it's not a wave propagating an
ordinary three-dimensional space it's not like one
wave for particle one another wave for particle
two the wave function doesn't live in 3D space
it assigns a number to every possible
configuration of everything in the world
okay that's a different kind of thing than the
classical waves that physicists had been so happy
about now if you didn't object when I tried to
convince you before that the wave function for
a single electron was a real thing it acted wave
like it interfered through the slits and so forth
then you can't object now I just put more
particles in okay the wave function is just
as real now but the wave function is an assignment
of possibility to every possible way that things
in the world could be and you said the wave
function is real and therefore Quantum reality
is not a bunch of particles or of waves living
in good old ordinary three-dimensional space or
four-dimensional space time it's a superposition
which is to say a combination of all at once
of all the possible ways that everything in the
universe could be arranged now maybe the amplitude
as we call it the number PSI is zero for certain
configurations and then we would say there's zero
probability of seeing that but still there could
be a non-zero probability for lots of things
and if you think this is real then what you're
saying is reality is way bigger than we ever
thought it was we look around we see chairs
and podiums and people and things like that
this is only one realization of what is
really going on in a much much bigger
reality according to quantum mechanics
nobody said this in 1935 it was an instant
conclusion you could draw from what was said
in 1935. Erwin Schrodinger sort of joked about
it a little bit but he didn't quite follow it
through uh it was left to a graduate student
30 years later 20 or 30 years later Hugh Everett
to figure things out and Hugh ever basically said
you've just been working too hard like this this
story you're telling it's okay that's why I've
labeled it quantum therapy there he didn't add
any equations there's no Everett equation there's
no you know Everett model or anything like that
all ever it did was say you have wave functions
you have the Schrodinger equation that's all
you need just believe in that believe that the
wave function represents reality there's nothing
else other than the wave function and there's no
collapses no measurements no observations all the
wave function ever does is obey the Schrodinger
equation that's what he said so just to contrast
here I told you this is the old-fashioned textbook
version of quantum mechanics two different
sets of rules right when you're not looking
when you're measuring Everett says here are my
rules there's one set of rules and they apply all
the time and the rules are their wave functions
in the obey the Schrodinger equation that's it
so this is now called The Everett interpretation
of quantum mechanics uh and then he left the field
never had an academic job worked in uh defense
analysis and died at a young age at about my age
now he drank and he smoked a lot and he messed
around he was a brilliant brilliant guy but he
could not handle the academic lifestyle so he
lived a different lifestyle entirely this is
his legacy erase all those rules see what
happens okay the Everett interpretation of
quantum mechanics it's not an interpretation in
any sense that's a very old-fashioned useless word
in this context it's a Theory of physics it says
this is the world let's make predictions using it
but look the people who invented the
Copenhagen interpretation were also not dummies
they knew that they had wave functions
in the Schrodinger equation and yet they
saddled quantum mechanics with all these extra
rules about observations why did they do that
why was this not obvious from the start so to
get there let's turn to the thought experiment
stylings of Irwin Schrodinger and this is
the Schrodinger's cat thought experiment
and I presume that you've seen some version
of this before there's a box there's a cat
inside the goal of the experiment is to take what
everyone accepted as true namely the tiny quantum
mechanical systems could be in superpositions
of different possible observational outcomes
and amplify the superposition to the macroscopic
world to a cat a friend of mine once talked to
Erwin Schrodinger's daughter and she said
I think my father just didn't like cats
so in the experiment there is a radioactive
source which has a Decay amplitude which means
that the source will go a lot of a wave function
that becomes a superposition of I've decayed and
I've not decayed and there's a geiger counter a
detector which goes into a superposition of I've
detected a Decay I have not I've clicked and
I have not okay if the geiger counter clicks
it opens a little container and let's gas
fill the bigger box in Schrodinger's thought
experiment the gas was cyanide and so the cat
evolved into a superposition of alive and dead
in my version of the thought experiment it's
sleeping gas in the little box the cat evolves
into a superposition of awake and asleep it's just
as good for Thought experiment purposes and no
thought experiment cats need to be harmed and the
reason why Schrodinger did this again he did this
in correspondence with Einstein they wrote back
and forth and he eventually wrote a paper about
this he was not trying to say like isn't quantum
mechanics awesome it's like Jeffrey said in his
quote he was a little chagrined at what quantum
mechanics had turned into so what his thought
experiment was meant to show you is surely you
don't believe that surely you don't believe that
I mean classically sure maybe there's a live cat
or a wake cat or a sleep cat but I just don't know
that's always possible maybe I just don't know
something classically but the formalism of quantum
mechanics says that in the Box there is literally
a superposition of an awake cat and a sleep cat
until you open it and you look and Schrodinger is
like come on gang we got to do better than this
so just to go through what would you say in the
Copenhagen textbook version of things and one
of the moves that is made in the Copenhagen way
of talking is very fishy right from the start
namely you treat your little quantum mechanical
system using the rules of quantum mechanics
but you treat Observers classically even
though they all knew that observers like
human beings were made of atoms and atoms obey
the rules of quantum mechanics for some reason
left slightly Berkey observers were supposed
to be treated classically why well that's
because it works so here's a picture of Niels
Bohr as a classical Observer and I'm putting
classical things in square brackets Quantum
things in parentheses so the combined system
before you open the box is that the cat is in a
superposition of awaken asleep The Observer has
not yet looked at it the Observer opens the Box
the wave function collapses When You observe it
and then either the cat's awaken the Observer saw
it awake or the cats asleep in the Observer saw it
asleep okay that's what we tell our students to
believe no questions are permitted at this time
so what would you say if you were ever it
or if you just didn't believe in all this
collapsing stuff well Everett actually called his
theory the theory of the universal wave function
because he understood that you know I I may feel
classical but I should obey the rules of quantum
mechanics just like everything else it's not
fair to just treat me as classically so he
says everything is quantum okay so that means
there's a wave function that describes both the
cat and the Observer at the same time and here
we start there's Hugh Everett The Observer we
start with the cat in a superposition and the
Observer has not yet looked and then the act
of measurement is not a mysterious weird thing
it's just you solve the Schrodinger equation
you solve the equation and see what happens
and what happens is the cat becomes entangled
with the Observer and the wave function of the
whole system evolves into a superposition of
the cat was awakened the Observer saw the cat
awake plus the cat was asleep and the Observer
saw the cat asleep now the reason why this isn't
obviously true it's true but not obviously so is
because no one has ever felt like they were
in a superposition no one has ever done this
experiment or the equivalent no one has ever done
this experiment that I know of but they've done
similar things no one has ever said oh yes I feel
like I'm in a superposition of seeing the outcome
in different ways you always perceive a definite
measurement outcome that's a puzzle well what can
we do about that well you know I did cheat a
little bit here already because I told you the
wave function should describe everything in the
universe and then I only put a cat and an observer
technically I should put everything else in there
as well right and like all the air in this room
and all the light coming from the photons coming
from the lights and so forth that's hard to keep
track of so we bundle all that stuff up and we
call it the environment so we have a cat we have
the environment we have an observer okay that's
a more honest description of what's going on
and the reason why it matters because classically
it wouldn't matter at all so in the box where the
cat is there's air molecules bumping into the cat
who cares they're not going to affect it in any
obvious way but in quantum mechanics the state
of those air molecules will depend on whether
the cat is awake or asleep because there's a
molecule that might hit the cat if it's awake
and climbing around the box but miss it if it's
asleep this is the phenomenon called decoherence
the quantum system that you care about becomes
entangled with its environment and you can
show this happens very very very fast almost
instantaneously so right away before the Observer
does anything the cat and the environment are
entangled with each other and then the Observer
opens the Box does the measurement and then
you get an entangled superposition once again
cats awake environments follow the cat
awake Observer saw the cat awake plus
cats asleep environments all the cat
asleep uh Observer saw the cat asleep
I'm not sure you might think to yourself how that
helps things I've added in the environment I still
had this puzzle I've never felt like I'm in a
super position but there I am twice with two
different states of the cat going on what's
going on so here's the same thing again at
the top this is the state that we're trying
to think about and whatever it pointed out
his his single genius move was to say look
subsequent to this once this has happened
nothing that ever happens in the first part of
the wave function the part where the cat was awake
has any observable impact on what happens in
the other part of the wave function and you can
show this mathematically because precisely the
environments are very different from each other
that these are what we call branches of the wave
function there's a branch where the cat's awake
a branch where the cat's asleep and never it
says it's as if they've become separate worlds
before there was one world and the cat was
in a superposition after there are now Two
Worlds that go their own way so his explanation
for why you've never felt like you've been in a
superposition is because you haven't been rather
there are two of you there's one that saw the cat
awake and one that's all the cat asleep when you
identify you in the wave function you're in one
of the branches not in all of them simultaneously
it was a little philosophical move that he made
and this is why the Everett interpretation is
called the many worlds interpretation and the
thing to point out about this is at no step in
the argument did we say you know what would be
awesome is if there were like a million worlds
if there was like a Multiverse like dude that
would be great that's that was never part of
the idea all we did was follow the formalism
of quantum mechanics to see what it predicted
and whatever it is saying is what it predicts
is exactly what we see and as a consequence
there's all these other universes that we can't
see but who cares it does actually describe the
world that we do see isn't that why we're here
not everyone agrees apparently so uh there are
objections and there are good objections and less
good objections I'm only going to tell you the
bad objections to the many world's interpretation
only because I don't have enough time I'd be happy
to tell you the good objections or you could buy
my book something deeply hidden it's better
explained there so the most obvious objection
is that's just too many universes I don't like it
this is the most common objection and between you
and me I think this is the only objection I think
this is the objection everyone really has when
they don't like it even if they offer you other
objections I think they just don't like the idea
that there's all these other universes out there
but look you can easily believe that an electron
can be a wave you better have to believe that if
you want to explain atoms and so forth and double
slit experiment that means the electron is in a
superposition of possible measurement outcomes and
if you have two electrons it can be entangled you
better be be able to believe that two electrons
can be in superpositions and once you go from
one to two it's trivial you can ask your local
mathematician to say that the Universe can be in a
superposition of different possibilities that was
always there in quantum mechanics Everett didn't
put that in the possibility of a superposition of
many many worlds was always there as soon as
you knew that there's only one wave function
for multiple particles the only question the
worlds were always there every version of quantum
mechanics has enough room for all the worlds the
only question is whether you let them be real
as a friend of mine Ted Bunn once said it's not
that Everett is the many world's interpretation
is that every other interpretation is the getting
rid of Worlds interpretation the worlds are there
another objection is this can't
be tested can't be falsified
well I have a simple objection response to that
yes it can it's very easy to falsify it remember
the theory doesn't start by saying there are
a lot of Worlds the theory says two things
there's a wave function it
obeys the Schrodinger equation
you could easily falsify that you could falsify
it by showing there's something in addition to
the wave function there are theories like that
you could also falsify it by showing that the
wave function doesn't always obey the Schrodinger
equation and there are literally experiments going
on to do exactly that because there are theories
that say that so they're trying to falsify it they
might do it that means it's falsifiable that was a
little philosophy there I hope that went didn't go
too far uh too quickly there but uh it's exactly a
good scientific theory now admittedly it predicts
things that you can't observe so what every Theory
does that you don't judge a theory by what you
can't observe about it you judge it by whether
it fits the data another objection is where does
the energy come from to make all of these worlds
right like there's a lot of stuff in the universe
you're telling me it's getting duplicated all the
time that seems like it would cost a lot of energy
so here's a little picture of the evolution of
the wave function of the Universe from bottom
to top time is running from bottom to top
the point is that there are more and more
worlds but they're not created equally they
can't be because you know you have to predict
a probability for measuring different things
and the way that comes into the formalism is
that different worlds have a different oomph
a different thickness okay a different weight
and that is reflected in all the quantities
associated with that including their energy
so this is one of the objections where if you
know the math it's 100 straightforward to be
reassured this is fine energy is conserved in
fact arguably the average interpretation is
the only one where energy is conserved but the
energy that is being conserved is the energy
of the wave function of the universe you don't
get to see it you live in a universe and your
universe is Getting Thinner and thinner it is
giving less and less of a contribution to the
energy of the whole but you don't notice because
here's the good news you are getting thinner
at least in the wave function of the universe
the relative size of you and the rest of the
universe Remains the Same so as far as you
can tell the universe has the same energy in
it all the time but secretly the amplitude of your
universe is getting less and less as time goes on
okay and then there's the more psychological
objections like again it's a kind of a
version of the first objection like you're
telling me that I am not a single person
you're telling me that there are parts of me that
see the cat awake even though I saw the cat asleep
uh what I would like to talk to them I have
questions right does does this mean like there's
a version of me that did ask her out on a date in
high school right like how did that world turn out
this is just bad metaphysics is is the answer
once the branching of the of the wave function
of the universe occurs the different copies of
you are different people they're not a part of
you in a different Universe they are almost
exactly analogous to identical twins okay an
identical twin starts out as a single fertilized
egg a zygote right only one of them and then it
splits apart okay into two separate people and
even though those two separate people were once
a single cell nobody is tempted to say you know
it's okay if one of them dies we saw the other one
they're not two parts of the same person they're
two separate people they're similar they share
a common history at some point but they're two
separate people and the same thing is true for you
when the wave function of the universe branches
the only difference is you can't talk to all of
your almost identical twins in the other universes
and what this means at the Practical level is
there is really no ethical or moral or
philosophical impact to all these extra
universes that would be any different than the
ordinary textbook Copenhagen interpretation of
quantum mechanics would let you talk about the
fact that there are many copies of you but all
of them have different amplitudes gives you the
same utility function or whatever you want to have
as you would in a universe where you could just
probabilistically predict experimental outcomes
okay so by now you're convinced it's the right
answer right ever at many worlds you're good
you're on board with that so but look at heart I'm
still a physicist I still want to do science with
this it's good to know it's I mean it's more than
good I don't want to downplay it it's crucially
important to understand what is really going on
in these circumstances but it's not just to make
us feel better it's because a good understanding
of what's going on at the fundamental level will
lead to better physics physics has learned a
lot about the functioning of the universe but
there are still questions that are not answered
maybe if we understood quantum mechanics better
we would be better at answering them so Everett
in particular faces a challenge that other
interpretations don't there are competing views
against uh the ever interpretation and they're
perfectly respectable taken seriously by very very
smart people but I think that it's accurate to say
that other than the average interpretation every
other attempt to make sense of quantum mechanics
smuggles in some classical structure somehow
whether it's space or locations or forces or
particles or something like that there's something
we're familiar with from the classical world that
all these alternatives to Everett take for
granted it's only in the ever interpretation
that you say there are wave functions and they
obey the Schrodinger equation and that's it
there's no room for extra stuff so in particular
there's no room for space or Fields or particles
or any of that it has to be derived it should
emerge from this deep underlying explanation
so the challenge to an everedian and this is what
I actually was referring to is one of the real
puzzles about everetting quantum mechanics is to
start from a purely quantum mechanical description
of the world and explain why the world that we see
looks so classical looks like stuff with locations
in space why is that that's a puzzle that
every other interpretation just puts in by hand
given lemons we make lemonade
this is also an opportunity
because like I said there are unanswered questions
in physics the biggest most looming one is how to
reconcile gravity with quantum mechanics you may
have heard of gravity one of the famous forces
of nature Isaac Newton found the Apple falling
Etc it was really perfected by Einstein again
Smart Cookie uh where he said that gravity is
the curvature of space-time is intrinsic feature
of space-time itself it's one of the forces of
nature there are others electromagnetism the
nuclear forces with those other forces of nature
we have a procedure we start with a classical
Theory and we quantize it okay we have a literal
set of rules for taking a classical Theory and
turning it into a quantum mechanical Theory nature
doesn't do that that's not how the universe works
the universe doesn't start with a classical
Theory and turn into a quantum theory it just
is quantum mechanical from the start and what we
notice is when we take Einstein's theory general
relativity his theory of gravity and try to do
these rules of quantization to it it doesn't work
so people invent other options String Theory Loop
quantum gravity and so forth and all of them have
been interesting and have had some partial
successes none of them has been clearly the
right final answer but again nature doesn't do
that so maybe the mistake that we've been making
is trying to quantize gravity what we want is a
quantum theory that gives us gravity we want to
try to find gravity within quantum mechanics and
this is a task for which the ever-ready approach
that has no classical presuppositions in it is
ideally Suited so let's see if we can do that
I mean yes a little bit otherwise I would not
be telling you this but this is absolutely like
speculation from here on where this is research
that is ongoing might crash and burn at any time
but it's an interesting thing to think about so
here is Young Einstein coming up with the idea
of general relativity and it's a very simple
idea gravity is the curvature of space-time
that's what gravity is he was inspired to
come up with this noting that you couldn't
tell whether you're in a gravitational field or
just being boosted at an acceleration like on a
rocket ship because unlike all the other forces
of nature gravity acts universally it acts the
same on everything so maybe it's a feature
of space-time itself you can come up with
an equation there it is again not going to explain
that but the meaning of it is that the geometry of
space-time is influenced by the amount of energy
the amount of stuff okay so Planet Galaxy Dark
Matter curves space time in some particular way
if you want to know what all those symbols mean
do I have the book for you I mean no I don't have
it but it's coming out soon biggest ideas in the
universe volume one will come out in September
and I will go through all the equations starting
from no knowledge whatsoever so if you don't know
calculus you will learn Einstein's equation and
what all those symbols mean by buying this book
I mean you could pre-order it like right now
so we want to know can you find this structure
can you find space time being curved in with
re in under the influence of energy just within
quantum mechanics well it's okay to take Clues
from what we know okay what we know of the
forces of nature that we do understand is that
they are described by Quantum Fields they're
not really particles they look like particles
in the right circumstances but they're really
fields at heart like the magnetic field here
is a picture a field is just something that
has a value at everywhere in space and what
that means when you get to Quantum Mechanics is
even empty space is kind of a fun exciting place
okay if the world were really particles then
there would be particles at certain locations and
nothing interesting going on in between them it
would just be empty space just space sitting there
whereas in Quantum field Theory every location
in space has a bunch of quantum fields
if you think that space is empty all that really
means is the fields are in their lowest energy
possible State what we call the vacuum state
if you think that there are particles there
that means the fields are vibrating a little bit
more it's all a different thing the fields could
be doing so empty space is not empty in Quantum
field Theory and we also know something about
empty space in Quantum field theory is that
there's a relationship between the different
regions namely they're entangled with each
other so we have different regions of space
this this picture is supposed to be space cut
up in little sub-regions every sub-region has
little Quantum Fields vibrating in it and what
I'm pointing out is that the different regions
have Quantum fields that are entangled with each
other with a very special structure the closer
the regions are the more entangled their fields
are in empty space in the vacuum so if they're
nearby lots of entanglement if they're far away
very little entanglement right again this is a
feature of standard ordinary Quantum field Theory
we don't in this path that we're trying to take
here deriving everything from the wave function
we can't help ourselves to words like distance
but we can help ourselves towards like
entanglement so let's turn it around rather than
saying I know how far away these regions are and
I can derive how entangled they are let's say I
know how entangled these things are let me Define
that to be a way of measuring distance the closer
together the the more entangled two parts of the
wave function are I will call them closer together
that is a way of imposing a distance a measure
on this purely quantum mechanical structure
and then if you know the amount of
entanglement between two parts of
the wave function and therefore you know their
distance you know the entire geometry of space
someone like Euclid or Gauss or Riemann would
be very happy the famous mathematicians who
talked about geometry you can derive an emergent
geometry just from entanglement within a Quantum
wave function so there's a relationship geometry
is related to entanglement there's also a separate
relationship that entanglement is related to
energy remember I said in the previous picture
here where it was all light blue this is the
vacuum this is empty space nothing happening
to put energy there to put particles there I need
to break the entanglement I need to decrease the
amount of entanglement between one region and
its neighbors so there is automatically in
Quantum field Theory a very natural relationship
between energy and entanglement and again we can
go the other way around when you have less
entanglement between one region than nearby
things than you would in the vacuum you
say I have energy there that's meaningful
and so we automatically have this relationship
that given a bunch of entanglement within some
big Quantum wave function we can both derive a
geometry of space from that and assign an amount
of energy to different locations in space and
they're related to each other with an equation
but that's exactly general relativity this is
Einstein's theory of gravity that space and
space time naturally have a geometry and that
geometry is influenced by energy Mass momentum
all of that stuff so we can at least imagine
alternative history of physics where general
relativity wasn't invented until long after
quantum mechanics and people said you know
given what I know about quantum mechanics
and given what I think is probably true
about geometry I bet that geometry is actually
not static I bet it's dynamical in response to
the amount of matter energy in the universe and
you would invent general relativity that way
so anyway this is what my friends and I are
working on right now this is very very tentative
I've sold you a bill of goods I've not told you
any of the possible stumbling blocks or loopholes
in this it's not a finished project yet but the
point is the initial indications are extremely
promising rather than starting with strings
or Loops or causal sets or what have you and
quantizing them just by starting with a Quantum
wave function and asking what are the natural
ways where space and time could emerge you get
something that naturally looks like Einstein's
theory of gravity we're far away from getting
the complete picture but it's absolutely worth
working on this to push it forward in new
directions or as I like to say it is time
to climb out of the box this is caliban here in
caliban thank you very much for coming tonight
thank you
um if anyone has any questions if
anyone has any questions please
raise your hand my colleague and
I will pass the microphone around
over there
it's dark in here so you had
to raise your hand vigorously
thank you for that mind-blowing discussion uh
have you or any of your colleagues who support
the many worlds approach been able to hypothesize
a classical way of testing or showing it or is
that impossible I don't even know what you mean
by a classical way of testing well I I assume you
can use mathematical equations that might point
in the direction of this and I'm just wondering
whether as a Layman like I like me sees the
world can you or any of your colleagues imagine
an experimental way to demonstrate that yes
there really are multiple versions of me and
one of us has a dead and one of us has a live
cat so the point is quantum mechanics says that
if you don't like it you can change the theory
and people do there are theories that are very
viable right now with hidden variables there are
theories where the wave function does not always
obey the Schrodinger equation there are other
kinds of theories that work in various ways to
get rid of the other parts of the quantum
superposition and they're testable you can
observe these in principle they haven't seen them
yet so my bet is going to remain on many worlds
where are we
okay go for it
can you talk about the experiments like G2 in the
next phase of LHC and kind of the discrepancies
there and how about my future experience sure so
let me rephrase the question there is of course
I've been very unfair to my friends in the
physics Community when I said like they came
up with a story in 1927 they've been sticking to
it ever since I could be much more Vivid about
what was going on there were literally memos
passed around in the major physics journals
saying do not consider papers on the foundations
of quantum mechanics there were people who are
making major contributions to the foundations
of quantum mechanics like John Bell at CERN who
wouldn't tell anybody that he was working
on it he hid his work on this subject okay
um why again it's not because they were dumb
they had other things to do they were working
on things like Quantum field Theory and particle
physics and nuclear physics that were testable
in a very direct immediate way and that is still
an ongoing project the for better for worse the
situation is we've been too good at it we have
a model called the standard model of particle
physics which is literally compatible with every
experiment ever done in a laboratory here on Earth
that's a terrible situation to be in as a
physicist because it's very hard to make progress
when the data agree with your existing Theory
especially when you don't think that theory is
right you don't think the standard model is the
final answer it doesn't include gravity doesn't
include Dark Matter it doesn't understand or
explain what happens at the big bang and so forth
there are finally getting to your question there
are and there always have been and always will be
anomalies we do many many experiments in
physics all at once roughly speaking they
all fit the standard model but if you
do enough experiments just by chance
some of them won't okay and these anomalies
sometimes go away but then the few that don't
upset the apple cart and really teach you new
physics so there are new uh anomalies especially
with muons there's two different anomalies both
with the spin of the muon and with the decay of
the muon that the muon is one of the elementary
particles a heavier cousin of the electron the
muon seems to be misbehaving just a little bit
now we don't know whether the misbehavior is just
our experiments aren't good enough or whether
or not it's really a sign of physics beyond
the standard model we just have to wait and do
the experiments better and the outcome of those
experiments will have absolutely zero impact on
anything that I said today because they all just
depend on quantum mechanics being right and again
quantum mechanics Works Copenhagen works it makes
the right predictions for experimental outcomes
at particle physics experiments and that will
almost certainly continue to be the case in future
particle physics experiments the reason one of the
reasons why thinking about the foundations of
quantum mechanics has become more popular is
because there's other kinds of experiments
where the Copenhagen interpretation is not
that it's proven wrong but that it's just not
up to the task because the dividing line between
classical and Quantum becomes fuzzier when you
make quantum computers when you put lots of things
into entangled coherent States at the same time
this is not what particle physicists do particle
physicists just use and abuse Quantum Mechanics
for their own purposes but they don't care about
the foundations of it and their experiments
are going to help us with it John over here
um I'm just trying to figure out how to
fit Consciousness into this whole thing
and I don't know if you're willing to talk
about that or even go there but it seems to
me that the the that Everett's um Theory
would work well with that as because as
we everybody follows on on their path in
a universe we we each have our individual
universe that were that we're living in and so
would that be a way to kind of approach this to
you know figure out that dualism part of it
yeah no Everett's theory is very very clear
that quantum mechanics has absolutely nothing to
do with consciousness that's the relationship the
branching of the wave function and multiple
possibilities you know remember we had the
measurement problem in Copenhagen interpretation
does it somehow involve Consciousness or agency
or anything like that in this Theory the answer
is no it's decoherence which happens before the
agent even looks at the thing it has nothing
to do with Consciousness thinking anything
like that that doesn't say that it explains
Consciousness it has nothing to do with it
so the puzzles and the prospects for understanding
Consciousness are exactly the same in everetting
quantum mechanics as they would be in Copenhagen
or In classical physics or anything like that
this is also a Consciousness question so Max
Planck said that in his view Consciousness was
fundamental and that matter was derivative from
Consciousness I'm guessing you disagree with that
and so my question would be what what do you think
he was missing what did he get wrong and and why
might he have said that sure look Max Planck said
a lot of Dopey things he never believed in photons
okay you know you if you're if you're looking for
wisdom from physicist 100 years ago uh you should
do better than that I think that it was I mean to
be more fair there was a time you know in between
let's say 1927 and 1957. when it was perfectly
reasonable to think that there might be some
relationship between conscious observation and
quantum mechanics because there were two separate
sets of rules right and one of those sets of rules
if I can find them uh involve the word measurement
so what does that mean maybe it
involves somehow Consciousness
um but we know better now and it's not just
Everett bohmian mechanics spontaneous collapse
models a whole bunch of other approaches to
quantum mechanics are a hundred percent physical
and materialistic they've removed Consciousness
from the equation there's still a lot of old
quotes from dead physicists that would tell
you otherwise but nowadays we should do better
hi there uh thanks so much um uh
earlier you showed a graphic of
um you know the universe splitting
uh as branches on a tree and so forth
um and uh that that picture implies that there is
an original World state so what can you say about
that original World State and I suppose entropy
very very good you've noticed that I mean I don't
know how what is going through your brain here
but if you look at where to go this equation
this equation doesn't tell the difference between
the past and the future it has no directionality
in time it works equally well it's just like
Newton's Laws of mechanics do not pick out a
direction forward or backward okay so this like
I told you the whole ever interpretation is just
the Schrodinger equation and nothing else but
the Schrodinger equation has no directionality
of time but this picture definitely does
there's an obvious difference between the past
and future what's going on with that what's
going on with that is by my first book from
eternity to here where I talk about the arrow
of time and the fact that it is not dependent
on the laws of physics from moment to moment but
on the initial conditions of the universe there's
a cosmology problem which is another open problem
where we don't have the answer to some of us have
ideas but there's no consensus about why the
early Universe was in a Quantum state which by
All rights is unusual is strange it's not random
it's not generic it's not what you would expect
it's very very special why some of us have ideas
Stephen Hawking thought he knew the answer uh but
we don't know so it's a great question we don't
know the answer what we do know is if you make
that assumption if you say that for whatever
reason our observable universe started in a
state that is very special highly entangled low
entropy or highly unentangled I should say then
it'll have happens then it all fits together
it all branches like this very very naturally
can you explain how theoretical physics
is informed by experimentation currently
it sounds like part of it is Blackboard and
shock and talking to each other what and how
do you come up with experimentation yeah so
I mean this is a great question and there's
it it depends a lot on what kind of physics
you're talking about I mean let's be clear
the kind of physics I've talked about here in
this talk is a tiny sliver of physics overall
most physics is in a state where a theory
and experiment are closely connected with
each other whether it's Atomic physics or
materials physics or biophysics or whatever
but there are times like I said with the standard
model of particle physics or in some sense what
you might call the standard model of quantum
mechanics the Copenhagen interpretation where
the theory does a good enough job fitting the data
that you don't have experimental Clues as to how
to go beyond it we still look so in the point of
that being in most theoretical physics very very
closely connected with experiments in places like
the foundations of quantum mechanics there still
are experiments going on this is an experiment you
see the year here 2020 this picture of an actual
experiment looking for wave functions collapsing
in violation of the Schrodinger equation
and if they find it that will falsify the
ever interpretation of quantum mechanics
um there are again the problem is the theory is
too good so I've made experimental predictions
about energy conservation and things like that
that seem to be predicted by quantum mechanics
but there's no competitor to Quantum Mechanics
overall right it's not like we're comparing
quantum mechanics to something else so we're just
trying to think of the best conceptual framework
in which to think about quantum mechanics
itself and for better for worse that's a
lot of scribbling at the Blackboard that's that's
what's involved until we get some good ideas that
can be compared in the lab like these are today I
think we have time for one more question one more
one more question one really
good one there's one right there
all right um I was just seeing that the James
Webb has all right has seen back 13.7 billion
years and uh it's just amazing could you just talk
about that can it see the big bang or something
like that sure uh no it cannot but that's okay
because we already saw the Big Bang back in the
1960s the cosmic microwave background is the
leftover radiation from The Big Bang now sadly
the cosmic microwave background only gives us
a view of what the universe looked like 380
000 years after the big bang itself uh the
earliest galaxies will always be later than
the cosmic microwave background the moment the
the micro background radiation for those of you
who don't know suffuses all the universe you see
it in every direction when I was your age we had
television sets that had antennas on top and you
could pick up you could get fuzz you'd get static
from the cosmic microwave background on your TV
set and it is left over from the fact that the
early Universe about 14 billion years ago was a
hot dense date that was glowing and it was opaque
and it didn't become transparent until 380 000
years after the big bang and we see the radiation
that last interacted at that time well we see
when we look at that is it's very very smooth
in any one region compared to any other region
the amount of energy density or matter is the same
one part in a hundred thousand so there were no
galaxies back then there were no stars there were
no planets no black holes all of that stuff we
think we're pretty sure grew through the force of
gravity taking the slightly over dense regions and
pulling more matter into denser and denser things
until you could call them stars and galaxies
but almost by we almost haven't updated to say
definitively that that had to happen after the
microwave background so we'll learn a lot about
Galaxy formation which is very important you know
like not again not all physics is what happened
at the big bang and what is quantum mechanics how
did galaxies form is super duper important physics
just like what kind of exoplanets are there
is super duper important physics and the James
Webb Space Telescope will absolutely help make
discoveries there it will be other kinds of things
that get us closer to the Big Bang okay could we
have one last round of applause for Sean Carroll